I'll go back where's pretty Pat how are
you by the way
that's alright no one cares I'm just
good anyway today we're gonna play some
more oculus because we haven't done that
[ __ ] enough already but I found some
really awesome games and I'm excited to
try them at the fire spot it's a horror
game it's called grey you scared good
alright it looks better already
god damn I think got him it feels better
- whoa job nothing far to do what the
[ __ ]
okay good
wait is that me it's me oh god I'm
scared about it I'm beautiful what the
[ __ ] you're creepy man
oh I have nice boots
it looks like a cowboy hat a town huh i
western the house i home well what is up
over there it's pretty cool let's go
over there this one looks a lot prettier
oh [ __ ] there's like a stone Jennifer
get out of here Jennifer
prepares I want you to stand hard
shut up Jennifer I'm tired of Georgia
toad you fat son of a sorry sorry but
can't object shut up doesn't matter who
you love
okay hello arm how are you doing down
there
I'm getting passed oh wait well well
death were happening
what happened about ah what what the
[ __ ] is happening okay that's cool oh
[ __ ] it's dark now why don't we do
whatever deal mrs. heck
I doubt our pets why don't you take
shelter somewhere all right I think
you're right mr. pills
I mean mr. stick how dare you get by
Deborah it turns me on when you do it ha
okay well this forest is pretty creepy I
like it
hello and he spooks out there hello
something happened please I'm begging
you
shut up here sit such an attention huh
how does that make me an attention I
don't know it turns me on
god damn it what
Eagles Eagles stay the [ __ ] away evils
what the hell was that I don't believe
in Eagles I don't think they're real
now they're not mr. stack what do we do
mr. stack what the [ __ ] god damn it all
right fine it's fine it's just Eagles
Eagles can't hurt us unless we're a
bunny I'm not a bunny [ __ ] I'm jumping
stop jumping you're not about it okay
I'll be fine we're fine it's just a
little dark desolate
lock out there everywhere we are
I think there's Eagles stay away Eagles
what what the [ __ ] is making that noise
just hug the walls pitch hug the wall
zone you'll be fine
we'll be fine kind of lost kind of no no
it riggo's eagle stay away you [ __ ]
eagle we're not we're not buddies what
the [ __ ] I I think we're safe I think
we're all good now
I bet Eagles aren't even real
what
well I share was fun right so the next
one is called rift drifter shifter
mister this I'm never gonna be a rapper
okay let me have my moments the trial of
the drifter all right sounds very easy
sure this will go smooth all right
what's going on what is this why am I in
a potato
I'm a potato what Oh
Shambu ah don't add you may think I'm a
potato just keep being a cat if you want
to start not by head if I understand uh
I am a Betty attempt at humor what a
human does not comprehend the gravity
but I nodded my hands what do you want
that be hundred and fifteen thousand
session of the transdimensional Court of
Justice commence do you know where you
are here at tourism cuz I'm a potato I
mean no I [ __ ] your such ok actually I
don't like you now I don't the subject
in the attempt to travel through a trust
I mention a rift was that what I was
saying
you see vehicle perversions I thought I
was having sex with the dot what nothing
I guess repute you to look betrayed
what are you looking at but that's my
favorite device you're wearing on your
face is it not this thing trial will
continue but we warn you become I accept
all charges or face immediate sentencing
what happens if I say no I mean if I say
yes ok yes
look salute to actually yes he went
report for what are you looking
as national traveling and sentence you
to life imprisonment in a dimensional
isolation chamber yeah not isolation
with George but sequence no janelda sir
but I love docks it's not my fault
please please I'll do it I think I can't
be eyes on and need love
I'm a love matter laughing my god what
is happening yes Oh what what what don't
what um I have a dock I can fly
holy cow my god
my dreams are coming true oh good all
right god damn it what happened here I
killed to write this with his blood
well you could have [ __ ] Eva Mehmed
least [ __ ] I'm stuck in here that was
pretty cool I like that one that was
very very cool magical drift harrowing
it's made by Finnish people and if I
know Finnish people correct this game
will be live up to the heroine hell yeah
alright show you song with arrow keys
uh-huh and let the Shaima yet the suit
up lat oh my god we have to do this okay
end of the shape may it belong Atlanta
so dad and Buchanan
so I'm controlling it with my head the
name jtimothy long a flat door
so dad until Kuno order said then I am
NOT posing hey there's our thank book
oh sure - it read or [ __ ] I don't know
the sign hey somebody rigged it this is
the most hardcore [ __ ] game ever made
hey what is the 46 percent so this game
is kind of like guitar hero but with the
oculus which is pretty [ __ ] weird
press space to continue what else do we
got
finish yeah yeah oh my I fell out okay
hell yeah preach it sister
oh oh my eyes keep falling out huh don't
even give a [ __ ] my eyes for that I play
the game with her oh yeah
not even don't you dare you that alright
the next one is called chicken walk so
apparently you're supposed to be chicken
and I think it's I think it's chicken
yeah anyway so apparently you're
supposed to be a chicken in this game
okay I am a chicken hell yes [ __ ]
come at me I got time oh hello [ __ ]
what's up what's up [ __ ] yeah that's
right
I'm the boss that's right Oh Cole catch
oh wait how did the chickens house yeah
I'm the boss I'm the bass all right what
have we got more time held yes MD best
huh what is that what that's a box
hey can he eat me I don't think he leave
me he doesn't see me Oh Shawn a says
Nick Saban the avocado
gobble-gobble-gobble-gobble
gobble-gobble-gobble-gobble [ __ ] say
me
Sammy Bechet oh [ __ ] he didn't see me
thank you what thank you later why thank
you better what you're my main [ __ ] now
burka
there have been upgraded all right I
think it's said I don't know check hi
ah there's a [ __ ] all right so friendly
you're supposed to like this be a
chicken and immerse yourself in the
chicken world I don't know what that
[ __ ] that means
oh there's water let's drink some hmm
are there like other seats on the ground
ha ha ha the life of a chicken huh
that's right
oh god oh god oh god [ __ ] gobble gobble
gobble gobble gobble
that's it that's a turkey god damn it
keep mixing them up
well what's over here and me that time I
need our time whoa I'm flying
I get jumpscared in the other [ __ ]
kids game oh man this is too funny
alright Prez I gotta end this episode
here hope you enjoyed watching maybe
like if you did it helps me a lot and I
really appreciate all the support
bouncing breaths
inside lab that wasn't on names Achille
oh no awesome fun you know